l'élagage et l'abattage des arbres pour
entretenir le patrimoine arboré
l'activité principale de l'entreprise
belbéoc'h située à limay elle travaille
pour des collectivités des entreprises
ou des particuliers
une fois coupé les morceaux de bois sont
récupérés et revaloriser le but c'est de
revaloriser au maximum tout ce qu'on
récolte comme matière d'avoir un minimum
de bon sens en revalorisant les déchets
de coupe pour développer la
revalorisation du bois cette société
souhaite investir près de 2 millions
d'euros c'est dans ce cadre là qu'elle a
bénéficié du fonds d'accélération des
investissements industriels dans les
territoires une subvention de cinq cent
soixante quinze mille euros du plan
france relance ça va nous permettre
d'acquérir le terrain d'un hectare qui
est derrière pour avoir plus de place de
stockage de déchets de coupe et de
et de revalorisation c'est reproduire à
grande échelle ce qu'on fait ici sur une
petite surface qui nous limite forcément
dans la dans la capacité de
revalorisation
[Musique]
aujourd'hui cette scierie mobile permet
de couper les grumes pour faire des
planches de bois ça sert bar valoriser
le bois donc soit on planche en poutres
en bois de construction bois de
menuiserie un peu tout ce qu'on veut cet
investissement permettra d'acquérir une
machine de ce type plus performantes
l'objectif est aussi de ne plus sous
traiter le broyage pour transformer les
plus gros morceaux de bois en copeaux il
ya la plaquette qui sert au chauffage
des grosses chaufferies donc aujourd'hui
ces plaquettes elles sont issues des
grumes que l'on voit ici ici et
aujourd'hui on externalise cette
prestation c'est à dire qu'une fois tous
les 2 moyens prestataires qui main
broyée et qui ne sert de la plaquette
avec laquelle on se chauffe et on
alimente d'autres chaufferie de la
région créé en 1986 l'entreprise
belbéoc'h compte 85 collaborateurs
elle réalise en moyenne un chiffre
d'affaires de 8 millions d'euros par an